all right guys bangbang I have Keith
here we are going to try to basically
just download his brain on the state of
the world and and go for as long as we
can
thanks for doing this sighs annuity for
those that don't know who you are the
very few what is your background let's
just kind of go through that first
people understand what perspective
you're coming from sure so I'm keeping
our boy I'm gonna partner the founders
fun I've been there a little bit over a
year after spending six years of ECF
Khosla Ventures so basically I've been a
professional VC for about seven years
prior but I I spend about 13 years of
Silicon Valley operating companies
running companies moved out here in 2008
2000 to join this bunch of misfits the
company called PayPal went through sort
of a sine wave distribution curve ups
and downs but eventually made the
company pretty successful after that we
both had IPO in 2002 and then later
subsequently sold the company eBay for
that kind of leave I did with Peter teal
and worked on incubating and funding new
companies you startups consumer startups
in the wake of the internet bubble flops
when basically nobody else was about
anyone to fund new and interesting
companies or the really Peter Reid
Hoffman
Sooni uncle who came to us had some
interesting ideas promising ideas we got
off in the very early stages
everything from became linked in with
can yell I got involved in both of those
companies as well several others during
the board so company became pretty
active angel ambassador
suspend the next three years or so doing
mostly that working through his death
hook that revenue generation at LinkedIn
after we changed to use LinkedIn I
laughter you reunite with our CTO
co-founder of PayPal Max Levchin at a
company that will not be remembered
called slide there was a eventually our
we build applications on social
platforms originally myspace but there's
people
forever MySpace and Facebook acquired by
Google
laughs that a week later after the
employer joining this kind of crazy
start up again trying to reinvent and
its recipes and microchips became the
21st employee prior to launch the
company thought that became unknown and
square and went through kind of a rocket
right there really really profiting once
we launch properly we're to launch and
come illegally do it and then you came
to BC but during the 13 years I wasn't
actively running these companies a
probably invested about 80 companies as
angel investor many of which went on to
be pretty interesting companies from
let's say lift to Airbnb to YouTube to
serving all over the map assessment Bali
I started as a lawyer I'm not sure I'd
recommend I spent most of my 20s in law
school clerking and at this circuit and
litigating of all things and then jumped
sort of cold turkey into the internet
world in 2000 you've basically done
nothing like it's like you're just
starting out yeah look I got thirty
something that the current standards
I've got over 30 I got about 30 years to
run the president has plenty of time I
love it
alright so you've had a lot of thoughts
on kovat 19 and kind of the health
crisis I want to cover the health crisis
first and kind of what your general
assessment of what's happened so far has
been and then we can get into kind of
some of the steps that should occur
moving forward but just what's happened
so far from your view well this is very
impressive
at least in Western in the Western world
I think the Asian countries had an
advantage because so much that Sarge was
an early version of the same and so most
of the countries that dealt that problem
saw or their generations of viruses that
are out of control and learn what that
might look like whereas I think in the
US and Western
democracy's either we didn't have the
experience or didn't believe it was
credible that kind of escalate so this
level and words basically caught
off-guard or with almost discipline even
though the logic made sense
there's a lot of fundamental emotional
disbelief but I turned out obviously the
virus did spread you know fairly rapidly
maybe not those dropping these people
projected certainly nothing like
smallpox or anything like that but in
the modern error let's call it quotes in
1858
really we haven't really seen a virus
like this in u.s. and so I think the
bureaucrats didn't really react that
well the politicians may or may not have
reacted that well they didn't really
react that well anywhere in the Western
world for the most part Germany has been
a little bit better but only a little
bit better than other democracies in the
West and so I think you know it's sort
of confronted visited on precedent
problem without preparation trying to
wing things in the middle of a crisis is
usually not the best idea I'm seeing
lots of mistakes by immediacy lots of
mistakes by the CDC lots of mistakes by
the FDA probably a mistake by a lot of
politicians
they've compounded now the pressure is
putting do about it for sure and one
things I want to start with is just the
access to information and the kind of
accuracy of that information so this is
everything from the qualitative stuff of
just hey it's bad it's not bad coming
out of China early on to the actual
quantitative data that we're seeing even
here in the United States still kind of
what is your viewpoint today it's like
how accurate is this stuff and really
through the guise of it's hard to make
good decisions if you're actually
looking at bad data
yeah well the data lives you know
misstated particularly but in many cases
of you know time to infection time to
test something get results you have to
covert at that time to have severe
severity like we have to be hospitalized
where you might die you have to try that
we cope it's like we do it our startups
and you lose the car
next I'm forwarding the data spent
amounts so that's one st. route and then
a lot of informations rapidly evolving
so those are all like you know pretty
fundamental challenges for everybody in
addition I think the Chinese government
had an incentive to miss lead people and
clear that he did which led to people
being more complacent around the globe
they surprised you know the severity the
human denied the possibility of human to
human transmission the severity of the
transmission the you know potential
impact variety of ways then research and
from both researchers and journalists
from investigating origins and you know
what was causing this in the first place
they suppress the doctors you know until
are going to kill the doctors in China
that we're trying to warn the world
so the real got off to a bad start
through the active mismanagement by
China with intent
after that the variety of reasons the
experts didn't react very well so we
were told that closing at worst people
to find out was racist which of course
it wasn't and would have been very
helpful in to be done even two weeks
earlier you know we weren't we were
advised that this can't be spread and
new to the air so you don't need to wear
masks cetera for doubt like whether or
not he spread to be absolutely yeah
because prevents it from accumulating on
surfaces not so fairly effective in
limiting the trends of the viral
transmission of the virus all the
experts adv need to wear masks from the
media for the World Health Organization
in just every single possible piece of
advice that the medical media world gave
us turned out to be wrong some of it
just sure you know difficulty of
predicting in a rapid the environment
world some of the think ideologically
suspect and some of it actually actively
misbehave so fortunately these days too
aren't alternative sources of
information social media being one of
the best ones where individuals who have
some access to data or ground truth
current quarter to the
roll and just disseminated social media
platforms haven't acted that well Zero
Hedge which probably not the whole story
right was banned by Twitter of someone
should investigate who banned them how
we're trying you know spies involved in
that decision secondly you know the to
this day it shocks me beyond belief that
YouTube is barring videos that are
inconsistent with the World Health
Organization where the World Health
Organization has been wrong on every
single possible topic about the virus I
think it's insane I think after the
virus was over the government absolutely
needs to call into economy needs to
absolutely go after Google very
aggressively investigate this very
carefully sunder and Susan cloud wish to
lose their jobs over this I think it's
not bad and you know the Senate needs to
seriously investigating Google's role
and basically propaganda and I think
that will but I don't think you should
do in the norovirus I think it's
something you do after everything is
calm down in the world you know with a
little bit the benefit of history but
it's not going to look very good for
Google I think the social media on
Twitter you know that was very helpful
as obviously our friend Balaji you know
as early as like January or in the world
that this was the furious of your
problem that it was absolutely going to
spread in the United States specifically
that people needed to start taking
serious action that absolutely did not
mask and vigorous testing invested the
technology at phrase which you still
haven't done are you the wizard without
but you know one bellwether was there
were early warning signs on Twitter that
allow some people to take action is it
larger than any experts that seem to be
somewhat right scott scott droppings was
pretty good he's mostly been ahead of
the curve notwithstanding because you
know fda background he was a VC before
that and maybe you know the ability to
first principles thinking has helped to
it but it's really
you know taxes via terror spent them
like left right ideologically the
spectrum is pretty broad nobody nobody's
big perfect here yeah so I'm the
qualitative side one of the things that
this brings into question is you
mentioned kind of YouTube using the
World Health Organization as like the
bar for accuracy of information
obviously we now sort the question well
if they were telling us not to wear
masks and then they have to reverse the
decision you know how do you kind of
give them credibility and so how do you
think about you know if you are YouTube
if you are Twitter like how do you come
up with where those sources of
information are and what can you trust
and what can you not basically doctor
security this is something that human
history has resolved centuries ago
we have standards for what can be
published in books you can't publish
quarterback of material you can't
publish libelous material it's been
forever tutorial other than that I'm
just gonna publish anything we want we
have you know centuries of experience
there should be no difference on what
can be published on Twitter reverses you
can publish in a book you should be on
Twitter it should be a YouTube video
anything other than not X no sense
whatsoever it doesn't work out fires you
want to reach a great you know logical
and circle work you know works on this
straight extra temporary min constant if
a group doing a great job talk about the
fallacy of content moderation and you
know the the mask example of w-h-o is
just the canonical example of what goes
wrong when you allow people sense or
based on perceived accuracy yeah and
then you also mentioned the possibility
that whether it's Chinese spies or
people with agendas on the political
spectrum inside of the companies
actually having a hand in some of that
moderation like how do you how do you
kind of break that down or evaluate that
is that something where an internal
investigation can kind of come to a
conclusion or do you actually have to go
to a government organization or a third
party to actually have a true
a kind of unbiased investigation to
figure that out you made some point have
to involve the government you know
there's like there's a compulsory
process you know that only the
government has access to in certain ways
in you know the Pentagon is always
believed that twenty spices infiltrated
tech companies in some scale Google some
of the protest gets budget David
absolutely journey by Chinese spies
Google's done some internal
investigations on this but at the end of
the day that's the province you know law
enforcement not necessarily companies
but I you could at least look and see
what they were doing anything suspicious
who was involved in the decisions who
rounded the decisions who voted for the
decisions and then if there's anything
that seems you know right absolutely the
FBI or whoever's the appropriate
operating force matrix you should be
consulted yeah the part to me that just
throws me for a loop is this one thing
if the whro or CDC saying hey don't wear
a mask and you make a video that says
wear a mask like very contradictory to
their recommendations yes you are taking
it down because it doesn't agree but
you're also censoring but I've even
heard of videos being taken down that
say simple things like drink vitamin C
because it boosts your immune system and
that's not a wh o or CDC approved
message for fighting the corona virus
that's what was really going to be
inaccurate meaning like people take
vitamin C secondly you know the constant
vitamin C controversy has been
controversial about all kinds of health
benefits as late 1960s and two-time
Nobel Prize winner you know mind calling
trying to get involved in sensor content
about things that are very debatable
makes no sense whatsoever because it
turned out that most things that look
mostly how many things that become
paradigm shift game look very odd and
very controversial you know I don't know
they took on the Pope otherwise you know
we wouldn't any revolution in physics it
took taking it on the Pope at the time
and that's pretty pretty company
for many things many of Einstein's
theories were pretty damn radical he was
a patent clerk out of nowhere that
basically changed physics in the
understanding that the human overstated
universe literally in one year and three
papers has some random patent Clerk so
anybody had filtered on the basis of
credentials or alignment with perceived
wisdom all of his breakthroughs would
have been surprised I just read today
and I didn't read the underlying
articles too maybe there's some you know
distortion here but the Charles Darwin
held a hold publishing or do species for
20 years because it was afraid of being
persecuted so that's not what we want we
want you know human emasculate requires
the publication and the dissemination of
new ideas new information as fast as
possible not as slow as possible and
that's what we're encouraging with the
censorship you know sort of paradigms
for sure
and this brings us to kind of the
quantitative data right so in New York
City one of the things that just blows
my mind is at some point they were
reporting 12,000 deaths only I think it
was 7,000 people actually had tested
positive for coronavirus but you didn't
actually have to die from the virus as
long as you had the virus and died they
counted you and then the other 5,000
were quote-unquote
probable deaths so if you died at home
and they thought you were you know
susceptible they counted you and so it
just feels like there's a lot of data
analysis that's going on data that we
don't have any accuracy or confidence
and it actually being maybe even
directionally correct let alone actually
accurate yeah when I company is
remembered as an executive the most
important thing I always try to teach
and apply is unique actual accuracy it's
like flying a plane you need to know who
those go for now hey any variable any
KPI any metric
we're not sure if the variances is
within the intellectual accuracy is the
most dangerous entity huge once you
establish the constants confidence
interval is above a certain you know
direction or below
then it's very easy just to not you're
the right director just how fast you go
but once you go when you do not know you
shouldn't be doing anything almost to
you to stop what's your confidence
interval and then just make sure you're
at least directionally right and I think
a lot of the decisions were made that
without the compass that were actually
right that said any new environment new
virus etc you are going to have some of
these challenges even with the best
people do the best analysis for a while
it's going to take deeded to some extent
but to sort that out but I don't think
there is a lot of extension k2 is
distracting right I mean they for
example there's a good studies out today
that you need the Western countries the
percentage of people who die that we're
living in nursing homes ranges from the
low in twenty five six to eight fifty
four percent if you knew in advance that
a Bjarni did two baths we're going to be
a function of living in the nursing home
the entire set of policies one might
actually thought would be very different
and in fact actually governor of Florida
was very criticized particularly in the
left-wing media and among the blue check
marks or Twitter it turns out Florida's
gonna have one of the best situations in
all the United States in terms of deaths
per thousand residents that's per
million residents economic amount of
economic damage I'm presuming you know
the citizens to normal these mental
states as fast as possible one of the
subtle things the governor did was use
various hue to the evidence that the
virus spreads in nursing homes and he
more quickly lock down nursing homes
than beaches beaches do not generally
spread the virus but everybody in the
media was focused on who the hell's on
each why are all these people on the
beaches etc whereas the doubts are all
being caused by people in nursing homes
in the actors for policies very quickly
about nursing homes so sometimes you get
distracted with the wrong shiny object
which prevents you from paying attention
to things that really matter in this
case if we've done nothing except
obsessively compulsively focus on what
can we do to save them and I stopped
this a little bit the virus spreading in
staff and it bums doubt among residents
nursing-homes probably wouldn't cut the
death ribbon you asked by somewhere
between 30 to 50 percent doing nothing
else purely and so the people were so
you know focus on should you be allowed
to go for a run outside should you go to
the park
governor Newsome still focused on the
damages in California you know trying to
leave any other day then there was like
two external transmissions of the virus
but we're doing all the wrong things in
anyways certainly the opportunity cost
of focusing on problems that are not
real problems you know it has major
consequences just as they do it our
companies when the executives focus on
the bottom things that by definition or
not focus on the right things accuse
those companies deliver subpar
optimization stuff our performance
compared to companies where the senior
executives know exactly their business
situation they focus on the two or three
key variables all the initiatives are
prioritizing against those two or three
there so for example in this case I
still don't know and this is a critique
that applies across the clinical
spectrum what's the variable were
supposed to be optimizing is it for
general infections hospitalizations guys
does death rate if you picked one of
those you would probably land on very
different policies about what we should
have done initially which is provision
US history so being on that point but
certainly respectively about what should
be open what should it be what are the
standards for opening sequentially other
things but nobody something in terms of
clear goals if you don't have clarity
around the pole how the hell do you hit
the goal with with tactical policies so
I think that's the first step and I very
don't hear any people certainly in the
u.s. of any political orientation
articulating a goal yeah well they taken
even a step further one of the things
that has been very confusing is as they
go to reopen a lot of these economies
kind of what are the metrics right what
are those KPIs that they're looking at
so that if at some point they trigger
something and they realize wait we
should stop right we should actually
send people back inside it just feels
like it's kind of hey what let's reopen
let's turn businesses back on because
we're getting that pressure and we'll
cross our fingers and hope it works but
they really don't have any sort of
granular understanding
of what they're measuring if you will as
they do that yeah I think there's some
real purty cure like what should be the
first principle goal you can argue what
that could be like some people will
argue to be zero infections I don't
think that's the right goal for the West
in right now but I think one should
specify what the goal is and then design
a set of strategies that maximize the
chance of getting there and minimize
collateral damage yeah well what if we
can go back what do you think could have
been done differently to get more
accurate data is it just testing and
actually doing it the correct way or is
there other things that you think could
could be a lesson learned so if this
happens again we're better prepared the
truth is this Bronner's people are
symptomatic for a period of time and in
some cases just testing people unless
return a state or a very random sample
or basically everybody wouldn't have
necessarily in this perfect kind of sia
because by the time you go get tested
you both had symptoms or any type of
exposure to someone closer than symptoms
and so it would have been difficult to
stop the spread just on a testing
regimen with the tests that were
available so scaling see any testing
could have been done better there's a
lot of your time to actually write it
did do a pretty good expose but the CDC
lost the ability to skills how stinking
you us really their work by the tests
available by the companies well they got
skill provide the tests and the FDA and
CDC in combination in allow them for
weeks arguably months that you know was
a major catastrophic error but it wasn't
a political decision this was not
something that was all dated the
Secretary of HHS or President it was the
bureaucrats and that those two two four
six weeks you know material impact
what's your thoughts around whether it's
a cure or some sort of treatment that
mitigates the symptoms kind of how are
you thinking about that
realistic is it that will one see it
into it in a short time period well it's
just like if you're you know you're
saying compress the time frame two weeks
you know what's the likely 2.3 love
months for you lo the quarters gets
better years it's better to sue anything
it does matter also that when you say
you know vaccine or cure are you talking
about hundred fifty percent like flu
viruses typically have a forty nine
under 45 south africa see some solutions
to major problems like true beta 2 beta
or whatever i was like a 99.9 percent
efficacy against HIV you start out to be
reckless so but i think we're probably
somewhere in between there were some you
know interesting stuff there's some
progress in israel today there's
progress and you can but even if the
even if you know whatever the substance
whatever technique they're going to use
proves people safe and fairly effective
scaling not producing it etc
distributing it isn't going to happen
overnight so I think there is a
sustained time frame almost at any you
know situation any likely scenario that
this is not something that we wake up to
you first
nobody stops or fingers and thank God is
too yeah you um you've obviously been
paying attention to a lot of the various
drugs that at least are showing early
signs of potentially working and you you
and Zach Weinberg lit up Twitter with a
knockout drag-out fight over what I
think to a lot of people was uh the
nuances of health care testing maybe
kind of help us understand just like the
the two arguments there and kind of how
you think about why your argument tends
to tends to be more fair well I mean I
was very straightforward I think any I
need a lot of people if are so blind so
furious to the motion against president
well anything he says they just stopped
doesn't matter what the topic is it can
be a like a recommended treatment
whether trying to you know was
responsible for the virus it can be
other policy exactly like when I'm
borrowing from uh actually a Buffalo
author policy stood is trumped
arrangement syndrome I think most
journalists and many people including
those popular Twitter ten-hut Trump
arrangements in the throat and they just
don't think rationally
after junk foods his name on something
and so the Trump endorsed you know the
prospects and profitability that type of
court bed clerk mean or kind of clean
zinc you know would be effective
I don't think maybe people thought
through whether it was or was not in
their kind of applying a different set
of standards should actually reverse
public statements I think the truth is
it's almost really not perfect panacea
or the people taking it you know we'd
see statistically very different impact
however it's almost surely effective at
least with some people give taken early
enough in the countries that have
vigorously prescribed some version of
the protocol using clerking or
hydrochloric in which is basically
malaria a drug that's been prescribed
for seventy years I've seen very
different results like Korea is rare at
all Costa Rica I've seen incredibly
different results with other countries
but however there's some studies that
have been done in a certain
controversial they're typically studies
that have been done on the drug with
people patients that are already
suffering severe symptoms I need are
hospitalized is it it's most likely this
is sort of like Tamiflu which is a
common treatment it's not a treatment to
come and drug prescribed for suppressing
some of the severity and symptoms
associated Lou tell if you only works if
you start taking in the first 24 hours
when you experience a symptom so a lot
of the media that jumps on those studies
and says they they it doesn't work but
what's not designed really to work for
those patients does not surprising you
need to take it very very early among
non of your patients but an in event you
know at some point this is not looking
at studied to doubt whether or not it
matters to doubt you know at some point
may be too late by time to figure it out
my general point the traditional way
science looked at Medicine has looked at
this is to use medical experiments the
problem is they think there's several
miles
what does they take time depends on what
the line is what the effect you're
looking for but let's say you wanted to
do a random controlled experiment on
whether something extension life we're
good luck with the eye
I mean like let's say you did it you
know so many hoover's boarding you're
gonna either lots and lots of users
because people that forties don't die
very frequently or you have to wait 30
years that makes no sense like read a
week to solve aging which is probably
more disease than a natural state in
because there's no way to do a random
control that makes no sense to me
I think we should be using statistics
and there's an example about statistics
working very well the positive version
of this was we discovered that there is
a drug that was prescribed for people
with diabetes defense to extend people's
lives and it just showed up by accident
in
secondly and this is especially among
for compounds and substances never
anything shown to be seen humans
generally regarded the state stop is a
lot less risky to just use pure stops on
but pure stops can eat about when you
can do something across the millions of
people tens of millions people hundreds
of other people you can get to an answer
that random fold experiments don't show
so for example if there is a bias and
country or toll so let's say some
genetic mutation is important if you
don't control for that in your old
experiment good luck getting results
there meaningful if there's some
variable that you don't understand which
we the rapidly emerging new virus is
moderately likely you're absolutely not
gonna control that correctly your
experiment you can even argue to some
extent some placebo effects are a
function of not understanding if it's
full route really well and what the
driver is so I prefer like not stops
math data especially of the substance is
widely accepted is safe over highly
style effective control birds but this
is a you know a very vigorous debate
traditional medical practitioners a lot
of their control experiments they grew
up in a paradigm of the 20th century
21st century when either this mass scale
data was available or this this district
it meets two parts in infer causation or
correlation which does exist
slightly Bertot and stats 101 were
profoundly understood to some extent
like we got to the smoking causes cancer
by cheating there was never a control
group or rather control experiment that
showed that smoking caused cancer here
was a mathematical derivation from
statistics and people said we're just
going to look the other way because our
ideology supports this so I think people
are there anything more critical is that
least minimal viable protein there was a
famous VA study that studied the effect
of hydrotherapy regressively retro
actively so non controlled experiment
insured it did work the same experiment
seeing the same technique was used in
another experiment where he was just
using retroactive data that showed that
hydrochloric Li was incredibly effective
like incredibly a product with a
probability of like sub 0 0 0 or 1 so
across any statistical significance
house the media covers one with Anik you
know headlines everywhere front-page
stories the second study you can barely
find even by not twitter the media
covering the the methodology between the
two students is identical I defy anybody
to point out any improvement in the VA
study versus a current law but the media
coverage doesn't stop when the reaction
got a thousand or more acts on the be
anyone so I think people are just
different very ideologically
hypocritical here so another way to
think about it is if you ask doctors
what would they do
34% of American doctors would prescribe
hydrofluoric inor some version of that
protocol to their patient if they have
you know early symptoms 28% wouldn't so
it's kind of original debatable and 24%
over but confused scholar coming soon I
think it is very debate
but the idea that there's some gold
standard that's magical and those who
are using other standards are is totally
ridiculous and people are being blind
because they hate Trump so much what um
speaking of Trump what would you give
him as a grade kind of through this
whole thing right are we talking a plus
a minus B plus C minus one would kind of
the grade B I think you got to decompose
I think in February you know C and then
say C instead of worse because we look
at what many other Western Democratic
leaders did in February specifically
wasn't it better in March actually
unless sure what else he could have done
I mean he's got his usual misstatements
insulting you know self enforced errors
and stuff he doesn't always express
things as clearly cogently as he
shouldn't precisely but the fundamental
policies of the administration starting
in March seem pretty damn accurate even
by dating because writing sounds but
that he hasn't everybody exactly what he
would have done differently
in March other than that tweet bus you
know and if you're a people less and be
more sympathetic but he can't I feel
also starting in March I don't think he
would've done differently so I think
it's starting dead in the obituaries she
got inside together he's been pretty
damn good pretty damn thoughtful pretty
aggressive and you know he's trying to
innovate trying to suspend regulations
that didn't make any sense for example
the FDA historically in the United
States you couldn't doctors between
state lines so we needed more doctors
and you are a California doctors
couldn't help but yeah you know basic
cost of all these memory bases so a lot
of positive innovation round of
regulatory constraints has been driven
by the administration and that is very
good do you think hopefully some of
those will persist I mean it makes no
sense
the doctors in California can treat
patients in New York as if there's
regional variation and you know the
perfect standard of care that makes no
sense it's very protectionist
so in any event I think the grades get
better over time
but I don't know that too many people
you know how great grades in February
other than some people need to country
particularly Taiwan to some extent Korea
less a little bit more makes in
Singapore Israel seems to have been slow
to the game but very thoughtful and very
productive starting March so it depends
on the country really but I don't think
anybody really like the Taiwan's New
Zealand it's kind of a different
demographic Geographic you know
dispersion there's a lot of issues and
you still dealing obviously and over to
new law yeah what last thing I want to
talk about the virus before we get into
some of the economic stuff is there in
maybe we're talk about six weeks ago
Zero Hedge came out with the the
connection between the virus and the
viral AGID lab in Wuhan not only were
people literally like hey that's
conspiracy theory
Twitter and the internet Twitter you
know banned them and I remember talking
to people and they were like that is
literally crazy talk fast forward six
weeks and we now have intelligence
organizations saying we you know have a
strong evidence that we believe this is
accurate you've had elected officials on
television kind of pushing this
narrative except not so much like do you
believe it or do not but how do you
think through you know one will we ever
actually know and then to kind of would
that change anything in either what's
already transpired or how we should
respond moving forward whether it did
come from the the lab at there and move
on or if it's kind of more of the the
wet market narrative yes oh absolutely
you need that one we're together some
people will know there's an article I
think in New York Times today the
natives Washington Post that said the
administration has electronic intercepts
the Chinese leader is talking about the
origin of the virus that's going to be
incredibly compelling the problem is
going to be whether the administration
is willing to release those or not
because by definition if they do it's
going to reveal how
the level the precision and probably the
methods were using to intercept you know
the leadership the communication with
the leadership of the Chinese government
and that's going to be problematic and
so there's a you know gonna be see
nificant tension error but yesterday the
Secretary of State said politically it
came from the Secretary of State is a
very serious thoughtful person everybody
in Washington respects him he was
previously the director you know the CIA
when he says unequivocally there's no
doubt that their stuff sitting on his
desk in my mind that proves beyond a
shadow of belief that this rj8
originated in the lab now I don't
believe it was originated by intense
like I think this is more either
negligent reckless disregard for human
life not an attentional like creation of
a destructive thing to on the world I
think that is not true this one any
evidence Koski but whether people you
know acted improperly had improper
policies that led to this problem
confronting the world I think it's
highly likely and I think the US
government and intelligence agencies
absolutely have evidence Scott it was
pretty obvious to me months ago because
again Senator Tom cotton is widely
regarded widely respected has
aspirations when were sure they were
running for president is very close to
both the Defense Department the CIA
who's a CIA agent himself he's been
tweeting publicly for months that this
clearly originated the lab he was not
going out on a limb he does not the kind
of person who goes out on a limb gives a
lot of reasons not to he was clearly
being fed
solid Intel that suggested this months
ago so I think it's inevitably going to
be proven but the willingness of the
government to validate this with
unimpeachable evidence is going to be
nobody's classic espionage trade-offs
the other thing that confirms this my
own - it's my understanding that the
senior Democrats there's a process for
briefing the other party both the House
and Senate
all just committees and minority
versions of the same then when there's
higher than we confidential intelligence
they are briefed as well and despite the
Democrat general willingness to
criticize everything every other it's
every policy they've been pretty data
fly it in fact I can't think of a single
prominent Democrat who's criticized from
on this specific point and I think the
reason why is I think they briefed too
and they kind of know the truth they
don't all look stupid and they don't
look at you know they can look really
stupid all of a sudden so I think this
will eventually be the consensus you
know whether it matters about I do think
it matters depending upon how negligent
or reckless the Chinese the CCP was
whether the appropriate reaction is to
retaliate in some ways or not and what
the appropriate steps are so another
thing it's irrelevant
I think they clearly mishandled the
communication of the severity and that's
caused a lot of pain on the rest of the
globe and was partially one way or the
other design to not look bad themselves
and to prevent exposure of the truth
down one is also a lot of damage it
could be a a fundamental justification
for some degree of retaliation and
reaction that that is you know syrup
unimpeachable that the Chinese
government suppress information mislead
the world intentionally at least during
a period of weeks if not months we're
going to assert the origin so I don't
think we need to go all their document
story they they are just or it doesn't
matter though if you want to kind of
understand what the life is do something
else
this is why it's pretty important is if
we're going to see something similar
understanding how it happened affects
your opinions probabilities about the
like things that have seen something
similar so part of the reason why I love
the Internet is the second that the what
was previously considered conspiracy
theory it looks like it has legs you
then get the other conspiracy theories
that come out from there and probably
the most legitimate argument I've seen
is a concern that this could be
you know kind of this decades WMDs in
Iraq type story right where there's a
pointing of hey here's a new enemy
because of X or Y reason do you have
concerns about that or kind of how can
we mitigate those concerns if they exist
well the way to mitigate them subject to
my prior points is I think the
government US government may have
through these Selman especially because
of that historical you know problem with
Iraq situation there's going to be some
people who are credible about it that
said it's enough intelligence Democrats
are aggrieved including some like Wyden
and they realize that they can't go out
on a limb be critical because you know
Trump will eventually on classified
information that need to you know at
least a non conspiracy theorist being
pretty nuanced so yes I think anytime I
mean look around each other government
whose credibility is about thing
and this is why you know I'm never like
President Trump you know it's just a
sociopath and a of public votes later in
May of 2016 so you know I think people
who would have this propensity to lie
about mundane things it really burns you
later when you need the credibility for
important things so I think this is a
fundamental problem with the
administration like for example the
first day of the inaugural when he got
in trouble manipulating the size of the
crowds I was actually pretty giris about
that not because of the crowds thing but
it's like that's the exactly when you
don't want to burn credibility you need
social capital and political capital for
when you have to you know Hospital
what's prostitute and but I think we may
be more likely the Cuban Missile Crisis
you know it can be actually how to show
the photos and that was very
controversial at the time Tuesday
obviously revealed the precision of our
satellite this but I think the US public
and restless world and I could
differently except especially the civic
Styles it's really put the photos out
there and it was pretty hard to be we
may not do something like that even at
the expense of admitting that we have
capable
the Chinese government in Doha and
that's obviously got long-term downside
of the patients that said I think this
isn't like a new enemy and I think
people should pay more attention to the
Chinese government was up to for a very
long period of time I think we've miss
judge their intent miss age their
capabilities and you know one of the
positives even though Trump is you know
not my favorite president ever he did
call it a ninja Trump any hospital
consistent attention I to I tried out in
the threat close by China
even as a candidate and as president
he's you know been very ocular sorry
light on summer of there was behaviour
and I think that's been healthy thing
it's actually becoming a bipartisan you
know sort of crusade
tonight it's actually in this era when
people saying but if you're
light-hearted agreement there is
starting to be a bipartisan consensus
that we need to trade treatment right
the threat posed by China much more
severely and seriously than we have over
the last thirty years I think that's a
welcome development and it does seem to
be achieving you know 50 60 70 percent
you're supporting United States comment
so one of the things that occurred
obviously is this health crisis and
we've tried to address it I think the
best that people could whether they were
right or wrong but now we've created an
economic crisis off kind of the back end
and really kind of the biggest point I
think is around this government mandated
shutdown and the shelters in place let's
just start out a high-level kind of how
you look at or assess what's caused that
economic crisis and good bad should we
have done something differently and kind
of how you'd look at that yeah
absolutely
pretty easy to understand we had the
best US economy anywhere by any metric
and we by going into the automated
commerce basically impossible and major
metropolitan markets so that will cause
an economic mess so the derivation is
pretty easy this is not a
consumer-driven recession if consumer
doing depression by any means is
government policy saying don't show a
lot transact and Weezer used
- you know that's called not some
employment because the people that can't
transact with others they cannot afford
to maintain employees rents etc so
that's the first the first generation of
this is clearly government Fiat I do
think that the government probably could
have done things better anybody didn't
con a suite in strategy if if truly 50%
of the people that were going to be most
devastated in one of nursing homes
obviously could have effect could have
changed behavior there immediately in a
very dramatic way without affecting the
rest of the US economy secondly it does
appear that social distancing is very
different than lock down the shelter in
place so the idea that people should you
know have more dispersion whether it's
six feet apart or some other metric the
the general density being a way to
protect oneself clearly does help in
reducing transmission and severity so
but people were adopting actually
there's evidence people are adopting
social distancing prior to government
mandates so it probably could have done
a lot of social distancing to cut a lot
of the benefits sort of like 80% of
benefit and 20% of the rules right away
in addition obviously we talked about
masks but Hydra embraced mouths either
voluntarily or by man be very early the
transmission rate and the safety
associated with virus or adults I'm so
stupid with the virus would have been
tremendously different and you would've
had a lockdown economy if people were
wearing masks either so I think a lot of
the most draconian measures particularly
that true shelter in places like in we
have a San Francisco which is more
severe and more draconian than many
other cities in many other countries
actually probably could have been
avoided without anybody seeing certainly
the hospitalization or their death rate
there's evidence that in Australia for
example Australia has had a very
successful management of the virus on
par not quite as good as New Zealand but
started later and has done very very
well in Australia some small groups
- these are labeled so below a certain
size assembly you can certainly go to
your house and visit your friends so I
think we could have probably known as
the virus without completely interfering
with people's ability to be sane because
I think what we're also doing is a
classic bubble optimization problem of
the health benefits both disadvantages
and downsizing the buyers are very
cleaner in the short term but locking
people up in isolation has been proven
for a hundred years to cause all kinds
of color disadvantages
what better depression or other diseases
there's a reason why people who become
isolated die fast when they retire when
their spouse dies etc so you do not want
to be isolating people more than we have
to and so even if you didn't allow large
groups large assemblies traditional
commerce we obviously want to get people
out of their houses and want them to be
able to see at least some people as much
as humanly possible unless they're
probably above the age of fifty sixty
sixty-five or otherwise
immunocompromised yeah and I guess part
of this is did they have another choice
right given the data we have like I keep
going back to it's easy in hindsight for
us to say hey there was probably some
sort of overreaction but go back to when
they started to implement this stuff I
remember I think was Hoboken New Jersey
was the first city to say that they were
gonna put some sort of mandate there is
shut bars and restaurants and stuff and
the mayor's kind of explanation at the
time was we literally had a fight
outside of a bar and rather than our
first responders being able to go to the
hospital and take care of people with
the virus they're responding to a fight
outside the bar and he was really just
fed up right there was no kind of
scientific data behind the decision so I
don't know how you thinking about like
was it the right decision at the time
and maybe we could have reversed course
or actually you know we just overreacted
at the time
well I think that's right I think it's
fair to say you don't look we have a
crisis let's take your Coney and stuff
right away but then I think it's also
fair to say well as soon as you put a
place for ponies steps that have
consequences we're saying what I gotta
cut off was neither some evidence that
the impact of the virus was more
concentrated in certain environments
indoor environments nursing homes
extender Islands so as we had more of
this evidence I think we could made
adjustments faster in some places and
that would have you know enabled the
economy to be less affected less people
lose their jobs less than the snv's Mike
Hortons to fail permanently etc but I
don't I don't critique the immediate
reaction let's figure out what the
hell's going on I did anything I think
we should have been more rapid and
shutting down the trouble from from
Europe more travel certainly from China
and then waited too long and you know
the whole history of the US could have
been different
we've been one two three weeks earlier
on some of those decision check knocking
bounced in a crisis is not a problem but
then looking how to the signals that
suggest I can do this to get like the
benefits was twenty percent of the
impact that's casa fossils also further
responsibility of how do you think about
on that government mandated shutdown of
the small businesses the decision
between like what's essential and what's
not
I saw that you you retweeted Jeff Lewis
talking about hey alcohol you know is
immunosuppressant but we have them open
I joked earlier there are a couple weeks
ago saying like it's funny how you could
still buy lottery tickets you can still
go buy alcohol you can do all the things
that drive government revenue I'm not
saying that they went into a room and
decided like let's keep our revenue
channels open but there's some
questionable things on what's essential
what's not like what's going on there
yeah I mean obviously this betrays the
idea this is purely just a whole carrot
rivet decision all being you know liquor
stores being opened is certainly not a
culture
decision is just treated correctly you
know alcohols an immunosuppressant
velocity you really want to do it there
optimizing your health and your immunity
system is for alcohol so I think that
was done either of coure the political
reality of avoiding revolt with
politicians are very attuned to if I
take away people's alcohol that are the
plane of my protests Souter soaky's or
maybe revenue driven that a lot of it
because all these states are depend upon
your cells of liquor revenues or maybe
both but it's clearly not in the best
interest we're gonna maximize minimize
Hitler deaths United States so we're
gonna keep liquor stores open that seems
kind of silly
I mean imagine like is so perverse in
California right now it isn't saying our
beaches are shut down
Clark's are shut down and the liquor
stores are globally open that there's no
rationality that makes any sense behind
any part of that state and anybody who's
you know people should be really
criticizing government Newsom on this is
yes you want to be a zero of defect
we've actually still oscillations though
that's an alternate break keep your
parks and beaches closed and make people
sit at home and you know suffer but how
the hell can you let them go to liquor
stores drink alcohol versus going to a
park for a walk on height 6 feet apart
for people yeah it's a it's pretty crazy
and I guess kind of going off of that as
well then is there's a lot of businesses
that let's say you're a CVS you're Duane
Reade so you get lumped into hey are an
essential business you're allowed to
stay open but the small business
competitor in many cases is being shut
down or not allowed to compete and it
just feels like it's very arbitrary
right so I'm not even saying that I've
got an idea as to what a better solution
to determine it is it just feels like
once you step into the game of playing
kingmaker really right saying hey your
business has to shut down but yours
doesn't it's a slippery slope that I
just don't think that there's a good
answer but but I don't know how you
think about it
you know some lines that you know
probably are more logical and more
defensible and they're something or
clearly judgment or judgment based bias
based lobbying based for example or
anything he wants to shut down the
provision of food you know food supplies
etc and so I think there's not a long
debate about that so if there's always
going to be line drawing
you know challenges and I think to some
extent the health like fifty different
states different communities within each
gate allowing them to join different
lines and see what works well it does it
is a great thing with federal assistance
give mo a lot of more I'm learning the
benefits I was in for the first time on
something for Tod certainly in high
school and they gloss over
obviously law school you debate and you
know contemplate the history of and
learn the principal legal principles
process it behind but instead of someone
abstract and now people are seeing you
know why they'd be better about 50
laboratories of democracy you think I
think sodium phrase the show I think
right now a lot of regional variation
and experimentation is a big and that
should apply to the definition of so
obviously that government mandated
shutdown has created absolute economic
chaos we've seen 30 plus million
Americans final first-time unemployment
in the last six weeks you've got
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
small businesses that are shut down some
percentage are not coming back you've
got a number of industries that have
literally seen all of their economic
activity evaporate my favorite step was
the third week in March in 2019 us
domestic box office did two hundred plus
million dollars in weekly revenue this
year did less than five thousand dollars
right around $5,000 so you got ninety
nine percent you know evaporation of
revenue and the Fed steps in and they
stepped in with all kinds of
actions what's just high-level good
actions bad actions how do you think
about you know their goal of trying to
at least M some of the issues and and
relieve some of the pain really what are
the long-term consequences about big
macro economic thinker and where there's
no price to these decisions but how
about is it a price so clear so for
example you're already a blonde cat
right obviously period um no the problem
though we're not is not quite as severe
Xin vitamin and other trends in American
history because the interest rate that
that deck current is so low so that one
of the things you care about is the debt
service love the bright day like any
other company say with the interest
rates too low the amount of repayment
pretty years are actually more tolerable
than it might seem
given the matter to the cat so some
extent it's unclear how this all bets
out typically you know these are bad
things they ship generally you know it's
just burdens to generations but the
generations to Toronto as well so
there's a lot of distortions that are
going on but in the short term and it
feels like that has minimized short-term
impact on thoughts around bailouts and
kind of some of the more specific
actions to either bail out of specific
companies or industries and for that
against that yeah well generally I mean
I'm conservative
I don't sort of like nikki Haley resign
for the board of go a you know because
they're gonna apply for government money
I don't believe the government should be
building out industries or companies
however I think we're government policy
specifically prevents you from doing
business because of some agreed are good
and there's an explicit rule that you
can't engage in business a much more say
that
to those types of businesses being you
know then being eligible for certain
kinds of government relief whether it's
a wall and whether it's about whether
it's some either suspension of something
but if that makes sense to me if the
government certainly interferes with
your business kind of nowhere and says
you can't engage in the business being
able to be Asian because we just shut
down temporarily that's a little bit
different to me they generally their
businesses are doing that well here's
about so that I think there are some
lines there that I'm more sympathetic to
not it and then speaking of the bailouts
one of the things that I think a lot of
people have not been paying attention to
is there's actually local and state
governments that are going to the
federal government for bailouts as well
so you know in New York City for example
subway rides are down 95 percent
obviously that's a big revenue source
and that's in a major metropolitan you
go out to some of these local
governments and they're really really
suffering does that same logic kind of
apply at that local and state government
level it's mostly the state governments
are making these decisions the federal
government has not generally shut down
almost anything the general rule any
empathy AACC right now our Commerce
continue you know as long as you don't
have a cell it works for people so that
it were unless you about a group of
compromised immune compromised otherwise
susceptible individuals so the federal
government has not said that you can't
engage the Commerce it's the seats that
are actually doing this is the state's
beverage possibility for the recipient
and also the states tend to deficit
spend or Liberty reckless in their
reservoirs like they asked me we've got
red alert about the states when the
stage know their overspending super
example California California gets about
54 percent I think of their entire state
income a state budget comes from an
extremely wealthy people in Florida
measured in hundreds to maybe a 10,000
and we pay for literally half the state
government states government expenses
as soon as there's an economic crisis
affecting technology half the revenues
in California are going to disappear
this is it everybody knows it's gotta do
something to miss this he's actually
admitted it to me years ago
no one is unaware of this problem but so
the government of come forward it
doesn't take steps to protect itself in
good times so that when the technical
lead or not making it on money than
paying for the entire government it's
not I'm not very sympathetic to oh we
ran out of money this has been a problem
it's been a known problem we saw this
actually the data was very quality 2000
2003 the government was less reliant
state budget over land but the pinellas
in pots was very clear even Governor
Jerry Brown serving a conservative
started to create a reservoir and
savings because he saw how dependent the
California budget was on like a thousand
people and that's an insane place to be
evil eternally so I think governments
need to take their obligation whether a
sideway seriously and the state if the
governor the government who wants to
shut down the state that's great he's
welcome to do that to protect the
citizens but he also needs to pay for
and it shouldn't ask the people what's
called the Brasco or whether to pay for
these decisions yeah one of the things
over the long term that people are
worried about with all of these bailouts
and the printing of money is do we go
into some sort of inflationary or hyper
inflationary scenario I think the
counter-argument to that is hey we're in
such a deflationary environment that it
can soak up the liquidity do you think
through that as you're making
investments and kind of what your gut
tell you it is the like the outcome
there you know these two please but you
know that you can't find any single many
deflation you see deflation of property
values do you folks are gonna cop it
commercial
stay so and they don't
I said not being a superb macro
economist here and not remember our
economics I don't totally understand why
there's no inflation signals with the
argon now that I can definitely tell you
can look at any economic indicator you
buy all the data reported by the Federal
Reserve there are no signs of inflation
in the United States at all so the short
term it feels like kind of crazy to
worry about inflation and but I need
someone much smarter than me to explain
that your conceptual framework of why
there's no inflation and what where the
negative which must occur where it
substitutes you yeah you mentioned real
estate let's go to an open door maybe
just a quick one minute on what is open
door and then you guys make some
announcements today and kind of what's
the health of the business we can get
into how that will play out through
through this crisis so you own a house
and you want to avoid the process of
listing on Craigslist basically we need
amenities like average and paying a
realtor 6%
for the privilege of bringing people
through your home we will give you an
offering roughly three minutes that's
finding and you can on your passage or
these three days and move out scheduled
whatever you want so you don't come
strangers come with your house you don't
have the uncertainty of clothes you can
go forward with your life but if you
want to move new cities upgrade to the
new house you can do that whenever you
need to and then so we've been live we
started the company brought in 2014 live
according to you cities basically call
it half of the US population plus or
minus face forty percent somewhere
around there phenomenal value
proposition basically it allows you to
basically traded or coops like a trade
of your car 54% of Americans created
their farm and they biting are the same
you know statement items should be
traded in your house
so we started this process rolled it out
naturally in March we have phenomenal
actually investment of the history of
the company more you know maybe many of
our markets flow positive we're doing
really well
Zillow versus publicly traded competitor
decided that there are their business
was archaic or business was archaic a
year ago said we need to switch lately
to copy open door so I think they see
the writing on the wall of where the
world's going to the everybody's for the
watching simply to sell their house
without this painted friction we ended
temporarily suspend operations across
the markets cuz government mandated shut
down orders
this tom excite us in most states who's
not considered an essential transaction
our business some states actually would
have qualified but generally speaking it
wasn't so to protect the safety of our
users or consumers please
we basically pause all transactions
tested our competitors goodness is this
- actually people realized occupy this
on across the open door is safer and
better than historical process it's
basically a contactless transaction so
that you can buy the house I went in
cell house first or open door without
providing visitors and stranger urge the
bill states your poll and in today's
world that's very compelling and
attractive people do need to move they
may beat the quiddity because of you
know or downsizing they didn't want to
move for new jobs and opportunities or
state for both environments so if people
are going to still move and we enabling
instantly we never have to touch peepees
so that's a more compelling value
proposition that was two months ago
and it's really resonating secondly we
allow you to buy a house but without
basically with all kinds of other people
all of our homes are equipped with
keyless entry and commerce is you can
basically 24/7 Vista house
house without having to go to an
attendant open house you need convenient
open house or schedule through a realtor
so you also cut back this way by
upstroke vidura which is also now us
were compelling obvious dietitian so but
we now stood in Phoenix were ready to go
alive again we're buying selling houses
as of today and in several other markets
but they a week or so will be lied and
then we you know bring on more more
markets you know back to business as
normal as soon as possible but I think
this is one of those clarifying moments
where the value proposition which was
taking over the world statement surely
you know I'm not the chair was growing
and every markets a little was you know
helping also explain to the world that
this is the future it's gonna be
amplified by a lot because if people
unwillingness to engage your stranger
and really understand that the media's
you know snap decision that gets the
money in your bank account within or
having to cover tens of people walking
through your house or these open houses
with 40 other people so I think we're
gonna grow much faster with the right
product the right technology the right
value I did a little bit blast to tell
Nelson they've been doing really well
but growing a fairly linear over the
last five years all the sudden people
realize why the hell they going to a
doctor's office for many many control
issues all they do to doctors offices
commute across the city stood in a
waiting room to get explosives arms nor
do that makes any sense for forty to
sixty percent of a medical needs
so telemedicine company something the
exploding on during this virus crisis i
thinka see anything is going to be true
to open door are the demand for our
contactless transactions without almost
is going to weeks I think you know at
double-digit rates for the rest year
what do you attribute the growth in
March because it was kind of right as
the virus was being taken seriously
across markets was it the market
volatility and people need in liquidity
or what do you kind of attribute that to
personal thing is more internal
operational all like excellence I think
like any company figuring out exactly
we're like
business companies like Jordache or
instacart we have a lot of people in the
real world they're all the state
transaction Elektra so she's figuring
out what amounts for those two nodes
battlers in master the communication of
value proposition I think the right team
doing the right things was really
starting to take hold the first word
this year so we had an incredible our to
a very strong first quarter just getting
everything right you know visit you're
always tuning your business equation and
your operation operations and it really
started to collect I missed the last
week of March and the first two weeks of
April will be your time for everybody
but I've seen some evidence from other
real estate companies home builders
cetera that past week or two eight-balls
starting to return to a normal wall in
Turkey GDP growth rate we new home
construction and new home Productions is
back you know in front of the arena
growth you'd like to see so I suspect
we're going to do phenomenally well
there's pent up demand to move because
people suspended for a few weeks month
baby moving
and there's pent up demand so so I
started to to to be amis
yeah and I guess kind of larger real
estate market there's a lot of people
speculating on what are some of the
longer-term trends that will will change
here so things like commercial real
estate will suffer because more people
move remote to being a migration from
very dense urban areas to kind of less
dense urban areas anything that you
think about in real estate where you
give credence to some of these or is
some that you say hey actually I
completely disagree and don't think that
we'll see that happen so for example yes
people will probably want smaller
well some people will value remote
working and minimize there could be time
however the density per employee may
also be required by law or by
attractiveness be reduced
so yes they have less offices but I need
more you know real estate / clay ah so
that make that out I think a lot of that
to be in business of course we fell into
the demand for certain types of external
boxes of red state eternal etc maybe
significantly the last Puritan the
fundamental economics of some of these
industries like restaurants if you need
minimum density I think you have to
rethink the entire experience of a
restaurant so there's some fundamental
transformations but and they let's say
account with a solo practitioner or a
lawyer they may have had an office that
they felt like they in office for
credibility this is working from home
for two months may cause them to rethink
whether they actually need an office
period and they may be more willing to
not have it out this and now would you
know that skill all this yes material in
touch with virtual real estate do people
shift out of denser environments perhaps
and maybe back you know maybe that's a
true trend hard to tell so I think
there's a lot of implications but what's
predictable right now versus a second
order of fact and a hundred people
adjust the reality is this clear to me I
think is a bit of theory that's gonna
happen of there'll be a lot of
disruptions a lot of transformations a
lot of volatility and it's gonna take
some time to routine where the real
transformations occur for sure another
area that you've got a lot of experience
with is digital payments things like
Square what's kind of the general you
know evaluation you have of that space
as of right now I know that you're
generally long FinTech and digital
payments but anything specific there
well online a higher rate than your two
months ago partially because the offline
equivalents have been shut down do the
companies that process payments whether
they're spray paint off squares that are
about to be doing well people are buying
you know large exercise equipment
whether they're like a tempo I got
involved in this is like we trading a
cold or economical fellow time people
are financing products like that through
a company I'm involved in called a firm
so people are buying things at unusual
rates which is leading to the Kenan
fibers or the loan provider provider
that service out world you're growing a
traffic class that's how much of values
a fundamental shift is on security
do people revert back to wouldn't have
the choice going to a gym where babies
my paula zahn when I had a choice do I
go you know you say mister heart for
delivery or my go back to Whole Foods
and you know serendipitous discover what
food I want and what not is hottest so
how much of this is a step function
change it just persists versus
extemporary you know sort of wave yeah
it almost feels like the virus has
accelerated some trends but also some of
them may be false positives as well
right ok since there's something on it I
think really easy let's start with a
deviate imagine you're gonna have a
first for second team what if you do
this last 50 years what people do on
first or second base they go out for a
drink you go to a meal a restaurant and
go to Nobu be possibly a play sometimes
a concert or something you know the
music might go for it did a few others
is type a lot or something most of those
options are basically not available
there like the top four to seven choices
when people going on a date or basically
band or unlikely to come back this short
term in the same way so the people
aren't going to stop wanting to go on a
date but they're allowed to get out of
our house so something is going to
substitute for those but what is not I
haven't no idea but the demand to meet
the lady how the common experienced and
filter and decide whether you want to
spend more time with someone is that
obviously that's or go to a coffee shop
like you know
people date away so before the virus I
would not have been willing to probably
fund a new version of first or second
date product
I think the inertia around these or go
shopping was chopping wallets what we
did in high school
all these seminary activities the dirt
was so great the gravitational pull
towards reverting to kind of normal
things we've been so hard to lock a new
dating experience but right now I don't
see people going to a dentist restaurant
where the cost of the meal is 2x I don't
think people doing a movie theater maybe
ever but certainly not at the same scale
music venues certainly not set up for
the initial host virus world so I think
there is a chance to create a new gaming
experience over time this is just a
metaphor of how there's a dislocation
creating an opportunity because demand
the consumer or psychology psychological
men isn't going to be abated but someone
may be able to channel it into something
completely yeah and I guess I'm the
digital payment side specifically are
you worried that some of this kind of
rise will actually dissipate and go back
to the more traditional methods or do
you think that it's something where
there is kind of a net gain but but it
doesn't continue grow at the same rate
there's just a plateau at that new kind
of higher level industry by industry or
segment by segment to see what pins we
obviously Shopify and we're just taking
it then you know benefited from this
trend is trading at all tire market
levels so not so now this is the virus
because people are doing a lot of clock
engaged a lot of commerce online
supplies the default sort of
infrastructure for a lot of those back
covers but do people who want to do
real-world experiences I suspect at
least in part they do there are parts of
shopping for things online that are
really difficult to do think of a peril
and sizing think of serendipitous
discovery I think there are great clocks
online for when you know what you want
finally and transacting very
conveniently a utilitarian
way but being seduced to buy something
you didn't know you want I think is
still extremely difficult to do online
and the real world is much better about
and people like people will definitely
vote with their feet about 50% of
expenditures or each alternative and you
know it's a specific need I know I have
about 50% of discretionary induced by
seduction I'm merchandising is that
euphemistic way to describe that I think
merchandising is still happen to the
real world but you know with the virus
issues are are ameliorated yeah before
we move on from digital payments let's
talk about Bitcoin and kind of crypto
currencies how do you think through one
what's transpired so far given that the
macro backdrop and then to what's the
outlook you have as that ever being a
legitimate either store value medium of
exchange in the digital payment space
good question you know thinking because
to some extent crypto has proven to be
less counter cyclical livable five what
was everybody thought for what its added
focus it seems to be something more her
lived with likes a called the Nasdaq
then you would have guessed I do think
as a store of value it's given the
draconian
in summer unprecedent steps that
governments all around the world have
taken
I think the clarity of why I look like
what take their wealth and put it in a
place that's very difficult or
impossible for the country to get their
hands on is probably substantially
clarified you know whether it is
Elizabeth Warren now saying running a
platform for wealth tax to the
government basically Fanning things that
people have done for centuries overnight
I think we'll need to a I don't want to
place some of my resources in a way that
regardless of what the government does
forever I want to locate access to and
so I think that demand is substantially
increased just because I'm one of normal
people now to understand that it's not
some crazy theory that I try to deprive
you of your livelihood so I think God
willing that'll increase missus proposes
forgotten I'm a transactional basis not
Sumpter yes there are kinds of
transactions in the world though that
maybe you haven't done in the paid or
trust reason so needed to be transacted
a person big leg purchase to the house
in India is basically sold out a person
so it trustless transactions if there's
fear of germs and viruses the need for
trust lifts transaction being able by
technology could Chris to so those may
be areas where actually the corn or
other crypto takes off because the value
proposition is just more compelling the
paralyzed three months ago
got it what other areas of your
investing are either changing because of
the virus or you're becoming excited
about that that you might not have
otherwise been looking at yeah I mean I
don't think we've changed our areas of
excitement I think we do ask it's not at
all easy Buxton which is wide so every
time we invest in a new company we asked
a version of the why now why is this
company more likely to succeed than
before
why is it more likely to succeed that
people who've done before time to do
something similar so as the virus
appreciate the world some things are
more obvious white house than they were
for example actually I invested in
looking about stood for 2-3 years
something that would make homeschooling
more successful and less coal friction
turns out that I'm writing nicely before
the virus but I could see why now more
people would appreciate it
so that's easier to not you but I don't
think so that we're just out seeing you
know a version of the why now but I
really want an answer in a push it's
worldwide is better more likely to
succeed then it would have been
previously where there is a change is in
the term there are three kinds of not
seriously succeed
founder driven and mustard market during
the dusters of technology jury
developers and there's a couple examples
at the high end of expert community for
decades that are one of these retires I
think it's been much more difficult I'm
a founder during a bastard like 90 proof
that my decision is are these the right
founders to potentially to pull off this
variable and it's obviously very hard to
evaluate founder to load late so in the
short term I feel like a fish out of
water
like I'm deprived of oxygen because I
can't meet new people in June is a proxy
but it's not a perfect box see it works
pretty well for people you ready go this
is a lesson about social cues already
embedded in my ability to converse with
people so even more meetings most of
words on the vaulted are executives of
teams have worked with for years even
the other board members from other
receives or people I've known perhaps
for a decade applause so they don't fuel
as difficult to pick up on those cues
but I think zoom isn't very effective
for meeting someone from scratch and so
I I have a significant I'm how they see
giving a difficulty and pulling the
trigger on new investments so either I'm
going to limit the number of new
investments in small these real board
meetings possible or maybe shift on a
risk
decided just about Celeste dollars so
maybe where we might have committed five
million dollars maybe two or three for
now as a new world evolved but I think
you know I made my first investment ever
in 20 years of the gusting actually an
amateur angel the with founders that I
had never met
basically this month and that felt a
little out there but the founders were
at least people that were one degree
removed from people I knew well they
both came from some sort of Facebook
Instagram world and so we have lots of
connections in common not my chief of
staff it actually worked with one of
them before I was like taking one step
removed for what I might normally do but
indeed feeling that clutter out there
but right now yeah it's very challenging
they're driven investors tonight little
driven type lobstering investors rather
than that difficult but at the end of
the day especially technology through
zoom call isn't that difficult and if
you're anything on the transformative
nature of technology you not bending as
much on the founder its lot easier so I
so much jealous of my editors that our
technology or Market Street investors up
but will be we got each other investors
will be back so for you I love it I want
to run through you've been incredibly
gracious for your time and so people
sent me a million questions I kind of
cherry picked the ones that I thought
you would enjoy answering the most which
tends to be you probably the most
interesting answers so let me run
through a couple of those the first is
thoughts around Softbank and in that
entire situation price is someone
personally selected into companies and
returned to them but I think the most
important thing most important
dimensions to that were twofold one the
strategy of dictating the winner in a
technology a market is intellectually
bankrupt that's never been true no I do
think maybe one example and ministry
technology but fundamentally the Knology
is not about having the biggest bank
account it's about having the best
opposition to the best team the team who
builds the company you built the product
you have protection if I'm not is more
important to your bank and in a couple
in the normal world accountable flow to
the people appropriate comfortable
floating the people have the right
knowledge with my team so that was just
surely wrong curated end of story
the strategy made no sense and wasn't
going to work suck it then there was a
world component to this which also they
don't spoken at all which is I don't see
how Americans are comfortable raising
money where the lp the primary they've
got arguably the exclusive LP runs a
culture where women are second-class
citizens five box
listen Lee gays are subject execution
Jews are prohibited I just don't
understand how anybody smelter Bali can
with a straight face accept money from
people who really are proposing these
schools on large components of society
we had a boycott of North Carolina from
some tech folks ten meters of tech
companies over whether the bathroom
signs were correct or not these are
countries where they literally you're
executed if you're gay or you're Jewish
or if you're women you're not allowed to
drive a car or vote the comparison is
record orders of magnitude greater it's
a crime to be any of these Menards and
yeah we won't do business with a see or
state that Papa's aren't Li you know not
the perfect bathroom signs so I think
the high pocket on POC Rossio people so
they'd be willing to consider money from
Softbank Saudi Arabia was stuff the
charts that it basically meant that
people you know weren't taking their
morality seriously so I think the
combination of the big thing is was
disaster so you know fortunately I think
that error is over I think it's
something from any recent going to be a
player in Silicon Valley ecosystem in
the future what was the most common
response if you were to ask somebody
like how are you comfortable taking the
money was there something that kind of
bubbled up and people used as the
explanation or excuse or was it just all
over the board specifically I never
heard a compelling you know respondents
honestly but lots of people are
creatures of convenience the highest
price people you know people work with
people who offer them more money at a
higher price sometimes at the expense of
principles and yeah I never heard a
really compelling answer about us there
are some people who are someone you draw
a I can see it compelling neutral answer
which is I'm actually not going to
impose values of class any the decisions
we make that's accompanied but then you
gotta thought you out that way and they
don't thing they do actually like out
that way so the family but I think that
would be a consistent intellectual
approach one can absolutely say like
mine to play bases a thousand people
they have different views different
religions different political
affiliations I'm not gonna get in the
middle of translating what's right wrong
we're not as a company or customers all
over the map flow we're going to be as
neutral as possible that is a much
little curing position but that also
means that you can't be complaining
about Trump you can't be complaining
about Trump's immigration policy
campaign complaining
North Carolina's bathroom policy at the
same time so I think you have to be
intellectually we have honestly
consisted but there is a way to be
consistent if you really wanted you got
it
what Oh how would your advice change for
young people graduating college had a
bunch of them asking you know hey look
basically I'm graduating into a virus
into an economic crisis what's the best
advice for me and anything that you've
said in the past that would change now
I don't know they don't change anybody
my way my voice is typically find
opportunities that will give you the
greatest challenge with the people that
will challenge you the most people you
can learn from the most orthology and so
you want to have this deep as possible
learning curve and as steep as possible
challenging further you can find I think
that's maybe not maybe maybe more for
fretted in a post iris world people may
be more willing to grant you the
opportunity stuff too but I don't always
be looking for the same things I think
number of people asked about some
variation of your longevity stack or
what you do from a longevity standpoint
what's kind of the daily routine right
now
well Sinclair read it up tweeted about
it so you find the links you know
whether or media laptop but the things I
definitely believe in not had any
assault rotation even high-intensity
game designed to both partially elongate
your telomeres reduce your extender or
two-minute recovery there's a way of
measuring on your Apple watch
you know the databases way I do believe
in severe restriction but I don't
personally do it I tried some variants
I've never been fasting which I think
does get you may be for 20% of the after
heard of pain and the benefits I think
those are the three things that are most
obvious I also will need and sweetness
to kind of see over everything
optimizing your sleep ensuring and get a
reliable seven eight hours less possible
as consistently as possible another book
I highly recommend reading on this
topics why we speak by not to Walker the
single best thing you can do for your
life for your happiness we don't
understand if you're successful
or I could save a personal experience I
was an anti sleeper and when I when I
started sleeping more it was
life-changing for sure another big thing
was around supply chains national
security and this whole idea of like a
resilient economy versus an efficient
one which was a a framework that a qu
moth presented a couple episodes ago
kind of how do you think about any shift
there that we'll have to make from a
seeking efficiency to something that
looks more resilient I agree that we're
going to shift to a more space exactly
the right vocabulary but a more
controllable supply chain meaning like
more under our control so you know for
example I believe it's true that there's
no antibiotics currently manufacture
than us that is probably a position that
isn't wise so I think we're going to
take a look at various things that US
society assault depends upon and ensure
that there's enough volume and
production capabilities and you asked
sure that we're never exposed I mean you
went through this to the oil room right
it's funny ironically not to look at all
have a stable place to it but um you
know in the 1970s we were exposed to
foreign oil and it caused a lot of
consternation and arguably political
decisions that are less than ideal
because we were dependent on foreign oil
and we made a conscious decision of
sliding into - not dependency on foreign
oil we eventually got to the place where
we relaxed quarter and I think it's led
to a lot more flexibility in American
decision-making and so I think we're
just going to do that across all parts
of our dependencies food paint drugs the
more vulnerable we are the last we're
going to want you know to do that and
there may be Bill Shorten mediums for a
cost I mean there's truth of the
comparative advantage is true like I
cannot look at her
Jocasta blow is a true state so there is
an inflation at least in some period of
time for some pre-retirement to having
taller their destiny through bearish
Danya factoring techniques now some of
that can be over some offset at some
point with automation we are capable of
investing into lots of other automated
ways to manufacture that would
potentially displace some of the cost to
the traditional advantage overseas but I
think we're going to have to accept a
temporary rise in cost to insure that we
have fundamental control over economic
destiny the road to recovery for the
American economy
what does that look like from a timeline
standpoint and any estimation as to how
many small businesses don't make it out
the other side of this so my estimation
is certainly measuring the quarters not
weeks or months and that probably means
I think this is more like in southern
valley vocabulary 2002-2003 they made in
2008 and so I think it will take a while
partially because they don't think
there's going to be a binary instant
healthcare solution it's pretty more of
a gradual set of solutions that add up
to being less threatening to all of us
and because of that economy's going to
be impacted even if not severely
impacted for a very long time
the evidence is true either China even
people did not even using government
stats which were probably biased or the
optimistic side nobody not snap back and
you get a conversation and the biggest
fear is that consumer fear which is the
traditional cause of the recession or
depression actually gets layered onto
government Fiat especially depression so
that even when the government
liberalizes the rules people don't spin
when they can't spend your disposable
income has either been evaporated or
their will their willingness to spend
kind of increased substantially because
of perceive also needed fear and if not
hop in said this would be a very long
recession I stopped then today
your sister as much as 50 to 60% of SNB
dismay Fidel that maybe that's a little
paranoid maybe that's a little
pessimistic but either the cushion
associated with operating SMB has never
been great the margins in many of these
businesses are small the fixed costs are
often high so I do fear that the furnace
and the devastation may be quite high
and then if you're right you know some
of the beneficiaries of the designations
of essential businesses have been larger
entities changed you know natural brands
maybe be disproportionately set up to
compete in a way that they work before
it was way to amplify the problem I
haven't studied you don't know but you'd
have to say this is a segment by segment
basis also depends upon the how certain
rules around density apply you know to
health care providers like dentists
apply to restaurant supply the bars and
all of us gyms how those were rolled out
and how consumers behave very targeted
to this moment but I think you know it
could be kind of straw that could take a
very long time once that I saw that's
moderately predictive is the month
before 9/11 occurred in the US we hit a
domestic in 2001 domestic peak travel
record in early September and it took it
to a may in 2004 to read hit that peak
so pretty pronounced and elongated in
that vertical and so you know that may
be a benchmark that's appropriate to
look at for the most effective verticals
anyway yeah one of the most interesting
verticals to me is just the health care
system right and how all of the
ancillary services and elective
surgeries and kind of high margin
revenue has completely disappeared and
they're having the explosion of the ER
rooms and things like that and it'll be
very interesting to see how many of them
you know have lasting effects from going
through this versus not yeah I mean I
think obviously this is we were
allegedly you know locked everybody down
to go to flatten the curve which is
to avoid overloading the healthcare
systems we actually do the start of the
healthcare systems of revenue to
patients that one may revert fairly
quickly you know I think a lot of that
healthcare push pull push moments of
what the surgery of treatment which is
split up or to be to more severe
conditions
sort of unfortunately after indictment
these people are going to get sick and
eventually neither a cell replace each
other so download at least from a 2-man
perspective may see some resurgence
pretty quickly and the types of people
who have the credentials nurses to
certain doctors who have been furloughed
I think will be in demand again because
that's a fairly specialized and
regulated sort of function so we'll see
but right now primary care practices are
probably the most effective it may be
permanent I can see a primary care
practitioner who let's say over the age
of 50 in a basically pseudo retiring and
not reopening primary care and hottest
sort of shortage in concerns about a
shortage of primary care especially in
certain markets in the US and that may
that may be assist there may be some
severe impact on primary care but in
terms of the hospitals and the acute
care I'm not as worried if they you know
if we're not locking out people for lots
got it last two for you the most
important book you've ever read
Sam Floyd high output management it's
really the Bible how to run and operate
and manage a high-growth startup which
is you know been what I've done for the
last 20 years and it's probably still
the only book that really nails it and
is something to try to reread once a
year the 1982 baby from a personal
standpoint the upside of stress which
we're so big max is Dean change my
beliefs about its obstruction to
yourself I manage stress a challenge to
be more successful happier and live
better and healthier longer etc but very
contrarian and most people didn't
believe my philosophy and so it's giving
me a tool for proselytize me in a way
that's incredibly compelling there's no
you cannot read this book and walk away
the same person with the same attitudes
than you did before you read the book so
I love the look that's gor copies of it
at home in the office been years ago
based a few people books through you
know my teeth it's not pretty crazy
about like this without it but I said
there's probably the most important from
a political standpoint the go-to lon
Tony so look at the digital anointed did
I read probably thirty years ago and
again clarified they were thinking
really reinforced manual thinking and
you know they actually probably still
always reflect into my tweets today only
you would name a book that you then
could use his firepower to prove a point
I love it
last question for you is aliens believer
non-believer and y-yeah this is
fascinating
I'm at least let's say you got over to
this I had a debate about this you know
over the weekend and it still was
shocking that and there last week
basically and I confirmed that there's
UFOs and piss about the third or fourth
or fifth thing that people are talking
about between the virus there's one
probably talking about the Michael
Jordan documentary then UFOs and in like
it's almost like people are so confused
by the confirmation in the evidence that
they don't even know how to express the
insanity or the you know Inca in
conceptual all in tension with
everything they've been taught I mean
think about this is a classic way to
close but if any of these social media
people or platforms have been regulating
content or moderated content based upon
credibility we would across all this you
have post up in fiction nonfiction
people who are proselytize about the
existence of UFOs would have been banned
from Twitter or from media them and yet
get Bell the current evidence yeah
pilot testimonials photos these days
videos measurement instrumentation it's
almost surely truth is there's objects
of some sort or that either violate the
rules of physics that we understand or
there are aliens or something and we
would have suppressed this for
generations if any of the people who
believed in content moderation and your
social media platforms ensuring accuracy
of the way we live in absolutely wild
times where UFOs don't get coverage in
and I think part part of it though I
will say that it had leaked already
right a couple years ago some of the
videos so I think make people may have
been a little desensitized to the
novelty of it but still the fact that
they they released that one was a big
deal but to also like why now raised my
first question like like what why is now
the time when you choose to do that
versus some other time I guess well the
New York Times to de crédit different
for each story in 2018 about this but
there is still a little bit more details
and the confirmation of the video or
absolve it's just even a Defense
Department is interesting I don't know
why now but certainly there was designed
to distract people for the virus to
definitely at work
maybe a little bit too you know dark
positives to the Trump administration
which is things that more traditional
style is when people take you for
granted
he's willing to rethink and
declassifying some of this you know
might be consistent with you know some
of those willing to roll really
versatile debates the way the
traditional press next operator wouldn't
of either party but it is going to be
interesting to see what else the
Pentagon and other people
this is really more evidence out there
for sure listen I appreciate you taking
the time to do this I think people
really enjoy it
where do you want to send them if they
want to learn more about you or founders
fun team members limited contents of
this table we have several podcasting
series that calling my solana puts on
every year
that's keen on it where we get people
interesting perspectives voice obviously
social media - later so my colleagues
Twitter some people used to at all the
Peters tweeted once so variety different
practices there but we like we will you
know we've some of us blog or you so
Stronach like my colleague tom ability
or two really interesting fascinating
piece about the future of Silicon Valley
growth markets to growth about state so
checking out all our perspectives we
think differently they're willing to
debate each other we were going to
unfortunately on a conference you know
make all pyretic on we had an awesome
assembly of speakers the variety
different topics that due to virus
concerned if I understand was falling
but will eventually bring that back and
you know explosive the world two
different voices divergent voices that
they probably have a profound I will I
will vouch for you guys and that my
favorite part about Founders Fund is
I've never seen partners at the same
venture firm literally fighting it out
on Twitter over a topic like just just
absolutely by person I can only imagine
all right listen I appreciate you taking
the time to do this
and they'll off do it again in the
future thank you